[Music]
daddy you see my round loafers I threw
those away why because they're brown
loafers try something new Henry
interesting shoes oh yeah the other my
wife got me these have you seen that
girl been fishing around in our trash
uh-huh you see it can you help her yeah
I promise hey have you seen my knee
what promise me now I promise
hey Jesus don't you know no better than
be sneaking up on people
what's with all the junk unveils um oh
yeah I'm an architect you know maybe I
could you're not one of them pervs likes
to touch little girls are you she thinks
I'm a pervert
purrs got mustache see everybody know
that hey mister sir we know where she
lives
set sail today oh no no don't I'm gonna
see my mother for lunch
the devil is coming don't be such a lump
you talk to or something you torched my
said that that was an accident how long
it took me to work build around her life
I have your plans right here I've got a
ton of ideas I really think I'm supposed
to do this to help you
let's get one thing clear I'm doing it
cuz I got no choice and if you mess with
my stuff I'll beat your ass got it
[Music]
Henrick I need you to get back to work
though is she I'm hoping her helping her
with what we're building around no it's
not but Kenny what I love this
they're pontoons should we just wait to
the tide washes a meeting what what was
he like she was kind of wild okay
we ain't lost our minds just lost away a
little bit I was wrong about you oh so
you're not a perv I'm glad that's
finally cleared up
[Music]